hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to video game the game I
recently reached out to Facebook to find
out what game do you wanted me to play
and I came up with a list this isn't all
of them there's the only the ones I can
find an immediate via blip it but anyway
the list includes beam ng dr besieged
miles from iron bread SCP containment
breach turbo dismount life is strange
sir you're being hunted 10-second into
facade in mine hands millionaire video
game the gaming do or die so depending
on which games those are utter crap om
read was that subtle enough for you that
will determine what games you see in the
future but for now I'm gonna play this
one because it seems awesome and it's
made by nuke our new grant by by Newt I
don't know and apparently there's a
major seizure warning so viewer
discretion is advised here we go
you enemies done kill this guy kill that
got him oh boy
upgrade I didn't even do anything
explore quality lies hope for you more
coins got China more gun more enemy kill
instead he just died points going oh
this [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] it all
game over what you gotta be kidding me
as all there is my intro is longer than
that damn game what the hell just
happened what the hell just happened I
gotta play back the game in slow motion
just to get an idea what the hell went
on what was that let's the cyanide and
Happiness theme god it's over I guess
we're done here I've already wrap up
this might be the shortest video I've
ever done but hey it's done so thanks so
much for watching check me out the
annotation for McCullar the demands of
I've done and as always I will see you
in the